after failing to broker the purchase of
green bean you I headed north to give it
one last shot not to keep obviously you
got me you like that one you like that
one
Wow look at that and there's a cruise
ship everywhere on that cruise ship has
diarrhea I don't think I've seen an
iceberg before they used to beat them
about ten years ago they were
temperatures this July smashed heat
records across the globe and the impact
was particularly tough on Greenland
nearly half of Greenland's ice sheet
began melting this week after
unprecedented warm spell hit the Arctic
region temperatures were more than 40
degrees above average there's enough ice
agreement to raise sea levels by 25 feet
worldwide
if unprecedented changes are not made
and made soon there will be irreversible
damage to the planet
[Music]
[Applause]
with just an hour left before my flight
home I was finally able to buy some
waterfront property
there's no way
I'm you know again oh wait there's a
little crack right here
Oh props props it just occurred to me
would be pretty if this is how the
Titanic sank they were trying to get a
gag iceberg shot hey hey cut here we go
ready now we're already drifting away
got to go back I need because I need to
get down here back
signs falling apart do we have anything
to it fix this all right go
no icebergs were injured in the making
of this video
[Applause]